facebook changes corporate name to
meadow moving aggressively to distance
itself from a social media business
enrolled in crisis and rebrand itself as
a forward-looking creator of a new
digital world known as a metaverse in a
75-minute online presentation zuck
urged users to adjust their thinking
about the company which he said had
outgrown its ubiquitous and problematic
social media app a platform that will
continue to be known as facebook instead
he said the company plans to focus on
what zuckerberg described as a next wave
of computing a virtual universe where
people will roam freely as avatars
attending virtual business meetings
shopping in virtual stores and
socializing at virtual get-togethers
don't forget that when philip morris
changed his name from altria it was
still selling cigarettes that caused
cancer tweeted democratic lawyer mark
elias and there's a few other things
here about meta i'll pause a little bit
uh but we'll go to that part right there
so there's some people that are excited
about it some people that are not gerard
your thoughts on meta
it's inevitable and it's you talk about
like a disruptive technology look at how
much time
people spend online right now right now
you know you have uh you know uh i know
guys man that day as soon as they get
home from work the first thing they do
is they get in the gta they've been
playing gta for two three years now
they've got millions of gta dollars
they've got millions they've got
hundreds of gta cars they've got houses
they have this entire sub life where
their gta life is like their real life
grand theft auto same thing with world
of warcraft and i think this metaverse
is going to make that technology
to the next generation seem like
what nes is to us like you know how like
when when sega first came out and we
were like these graphics can't get any
better my god it's incredible and now
you look at the graphics today and it's
insane this metaverse
you're gonna have a generation of people
who just literally lay on their couch
like they're hooked into the matrix and
they walk around with their eyes closed
all day they have relationships online
they'll have sex online they'll have
jobs online they will they will wake up
there will be people that work in the
metaverse they will the only time that
they will be out out of the oculus the
only time that they will be in reality
is when they have to eat they have to
[ __ ] and they have to sleep they may
even be able to sleep in the metaverse i
i know that that sounds draconian i
don't necessarily know that it's bad i
think it's bad i think you're gonna have
society kind of drift into two different
directions in two actual realities
you're gonna have a reality in the the
functional world the real world if you
will in a completely separate reality
probably with different rules different
governments in this digital reality i
think the actual world itself is going
to split into two simultaneous realities
let me ask you what what what has
dramatically changed in the last four 40
years let me ask the question and you
give me something say four or four four
zero 40 years what has dramatically
changed in the last four years okay so
how we how we uh communicate with each
other obviously because of social media
dramatically internet email internet
fine okay cell phone's fine uh
how about dating has dating dramatically
changed in the last 20 years forget
about 40 years so dating absolutely
tinder 10 years ago to today okay
fantastic let me ask you this so what
were some things that happened that
parents were worried about parents were
worried about rock and roll music with
elvis presley hips moving it's going to
get girls to do this what if my daughter
does this okay has music changed
dramatically from 80s i want to know
what love is to now hey i was you know
doing your girl with my gucci
so you know hit him up is slightly
different than you know uh uh
what do you call it uh yeah whatever
songs you want to talk about right
faithfully or don't stop believing it's
a very different uh a narrative with the
songs okay how much has porn changed has
porn changed over the last four years
i know i mean nobody at the stables
watch it but for the people that do
watch porn what i do know is tom knows a
lot about marijuana for whatever reason
gerard knows a lot about porn i don't
know what it is okay but but here's a
question though how much has porn
changed the last 40 years okay so go
back 40 years ago 40 years ago was what
vhs la express playboy magazine hustler
all of these things so how's it changed
now then it went to
vhs then it went to let's just say
napster then it went to
you know cds then youtube not youtube
but
pornhub whatever how much has it changed
though has it changed really that much
i know but has it dramatically changed
has the experience changed it's still
you
you know as a single man or person
that's watching it you're consuming so
the part where i'm going with this is
experience has changed significantly but
in on from the 10 000 foot view no at
the end of the day it's still you and
you are by the way you just gave me more
that's where i was going with this vr
porn is metaverse by the way but the
part i was going with you is the
following how much has uh uh being a
dancer 20 years ago versus today is it
even worth you dancing today instead of
being on pornhub i don't know how strip
clubs exist that's nice
but that's that's that's something
that's really a business model so do you
think people are still want to go see
the real strip club versus going on
pornhub okay all right so perfect if
you're saying yes do you think a 20 year
old i wonder if the demographics show
the younger generation is as excited
about strip clubs as 40 year olds are i
don't know okay so then then we have to
go and try to think like an 18 year old
20 year old today
with what meta is going to do and how
they're going to process this with
versus us because to them it's going to
be normal to us it's kind of like weird
right so we have to think like the
people who think it's normal not just
think like us who think this [ __ ] is
weird right so how much has it really
changed for them
i could see it being to the point where
like the government has to regulate
how much time you can spend in the
metaverse because people will spend 20
hours a day in the metaverse it's so
much better than their regular life
you're born into poverty you're short
you're fat you're whatever and in the
metaverse you're tall you're attractive
you're you're rich they're gonna live
their life there as opposed to in the
real world so much so that the
government will probably regulate you've
been online for 10 hours and then
they'll be black they'll be they'll be
black market metaverse
places where people can go into
somebody's basement and hooked back in
it's a drug they even talk right now
video games are drug there was that
athlete that lost his career because he
was playing the tight end for the for
the broncos he literally had a grand
theft auto addiction he was like i
skipping practice to play grand theft
auto it was serotonin in his brain it
was
dude the the
we we're all addicted to our cell phones
we're addicted
but okay so folks if you're listening to
this i'm actually curious i want to read
your commentary what are your thoughts
what's your biggest matter of fact
what's your biggest concern and then
we'll talk about you know the the stuff
that could be good i'll make one more
point cause i've been talking too much
but the the the
we talked about this when was the last
time remember when you would come home
and your there would be one phone and
somebody would call during dinner your
dad would get so pissed off and he'd
take the phone and put it off the hook
so nobody else could contact you that
night yeah what was the last time our
phone's been off the hook
yeah never well i'll give you i'll give
you another perspective here the the the
rules of the game have changed back you
said what's the difference between 20
years ago 40 years ago back in the day
the rules were completely different
they've been flipped what were the what
were the rules don't get in cars with
strangers don't meet random people
online
get out of your house and do things and
play now it's
you know you're getting in cars with
strangers ricker's getting doing
business deals learning last names while
he's in cars
right
people are meeting people online on the
regular that's how people date these
days you know speaking of not getting
out of your house now you're locked down
in your house the rules of the game have
changed but that
you know facebook has basically put the
world on notice that they are coming
after the future they are not just a
social media platform at this point
where you can you know rate hot girls or
be friends or check the news they're
basically saying live your life in our
world now right and this is what mark
like
mark zuckerberg
more than anyone with this this move
right here i could see taking over the
world people talk about elon musk or
jeff bezos mark zuckerberg is now coming
after your mind and your dreams and
basically your entire life with this
meta it's no longer facebook
it's the matrix it's avatar and and
there's parts of it that like hey wake
up see what's going on here you know
tico's living in this world right now
and there's parts of it like if i'm a
boomer out there and i'm thinking
what the hell is going on here if
there's anything we've learned from this
past two years of zoom meetings and how
effective it is and hey you can just be
anywhere
there's something the fact that we're
sitting here hey how you doing pat we're
touching yeah let's not forget about
humans need interaction
and this metaverse is cute and all but
at some point you need to get out of
your house and do real stuff okay
somebody just said mr bruce kim and i
want to hear from others gerard to see
what others have to say as well i'm
going to go to them uh tom uh tom i'm
going to come to you ricky if you got
thoughts i want to hear from you as well
so here's what some people have to say
matthew mason said zuck is influenced
okay stefan kariva said real player one
which i don't know if you've seen that
movie or not it's actually very
interesting yes um
marisol esparza said obesity is a
concern for our children mr bruce said
meta is evil uh uh trc turtle island
said will durant the age of decedents
which i've read a lot of will durant
back in the days so uh
this is cj deaths first time i've ever
heard a comment like that adam is wrong
uh the next one andy h it's not the real
world it's a jail it's matrix okay dancy
anthill said control freak rules so look
you know it's it's concerning but you
know sometimes parents are worried about
losing their kids like it's like i'm
gonna lose my kids
this is one of those things where you
can actually lose your kids and the
attention tom what are your thoughts so
as a parent what are you thinking about
this well i've been worried i spent a
little bit of time in video games and um
in the industry and i can take you back
to march 1999 which was the origin of uh
sony online entertainment everquest and
everquest was
one of the first massively multiplayer
online role-playing games here you had
an avatar you collect stuff you buy
weapons you buy things you
and people will go in that and they
would be playing for 20 hours straight
um
true story and it unlocked for me
understanding you know what the human
human capacity for addiction and
and to be to satisfy something beyond
yourself has never changed our ability
as humans to be addicted whether it's
video games or drugs or music or
something and you get so immersed in it
that it's that it's there
now
that that really worried me there were
people that had stopped playing
everquest that were still paying 99 a
month and people would say why are you
doing that you're paying 240 a year yeah
i don't want to lose my avatar i got my
avatar i got all my activity i got
everything in there and that told me
right there just how scary it was and i
started seeing you know fortnite
remember fortnight fortnight first came
out you know and you're dropping into
the island fortnite and baseball guys do
you remember when there was two of those
consoles it was in the boston red sox
locker room and they were playing it and
david price missed a start because he
had cramping in his thumb wow because on
that thing and they were he was playing
fortnight to 3 a.m he comes to the david
price was cy young when was he a cy
young woman or no i thought he was a
side well he was a woman
i worked at 10 pitch david price one
time so i i am i think as a parent you
better put timers and you need human
interaction and you should put timers
and restrictions on your kids getting in
these immersive video games because the
gaming industry knew in 1999 there's
billions and billions of dollars to be
made
off your kids because of our natural how
much worse is this though that's what i
want to know is this like it is nine
times 10. no it's a hundred times worse
because zuckerberg's involved all right
and i agree with adam he wants to take
over the world here's his biggest
problem he's the world's worst salesman
he literally is he has no charisma you
automatically hate him if you know his
track record so he's not going to be
able to sell people on this new con
concept i don't like him you know i i'm
less interested in meta if he had
someone with some
looks like yeah it would be different if
elon musk was in front of this i mean
you might believe it or want to get into
it hey the whole thing the whole world
you guys are describing is scary to me
um my kids aren't allowed to play
fortnite i never let them spend any time
playing those addictive games there's no
way i prefer the real world i prefer
human beings it's just the way it is and
that's
not going to change and i can understand
i mean this is just a trap this is a
jail cell for young people that are
going to get sucked into this they're
going to remain single their whole life
they will be able to
live their whole life inside this
metaverse and zuckerberg knows it
so you know this is a convenient way for
him to rebrand the company which he's
still going to be all involved in
facebook i mean that's not going away
what they do but it's a marketing move
for him and and i think him as the
world's worst salesman which he is um
he's not going to be able to rule let me
tell you something as much as i agree
with you
for being the world's worst salesman
he's doing a lot of sales he's doing
okay no but i'm like he's doing pretty
on camera i'm talking about when she is
front and center i know his company is
doing great of course it is he's got the
best engineers in the world i'm talking
about him as the face of it i i i don't
think that's hard to argue with
you made a great point and whoever did
that super chat is right about it being
a little bit of a jail look at how
they're controlling information right
now look at how they're controlling
speech say the wrong thing you're shut
down imagine being addicted to that
metaverse this is where you're online
this is where your job is this is where
your girlfriend is it's online you're
dating somebody in in three you know 5
000 miles away halfway around the world
they they're on the metaverse you're in
love with this life but you said the
wrong thing so now we're going to shut
you down for 30 days you can't get on
the metaverse you can't go to work you
voted the wrong way
you you you
ate red meat it was detected in your uh
your bio scans detected that's the
social credit score that they're doing
in china exactly but in the metaverse
now exactly they'll throttle your reach
here you are all your friends is
it is very scary as people who have
grown up in the real world yeah the
thought of this yeah pat made up a good
point if you're 12 15
you you've got kids all between you know
six and 15 like this is quite the
concern if you're if you're a parent let
me let me okay so that's that's the
that's the part that's the part i read a
uh time magazine article that said uh
minimalist how the next generation is
minimalist and this was like eight years
ago seven years ago and in the articles
no not not minimalist it was time on
narcissists had the next how narcissists
they are and they were talking about all
these 14 year kids want to do is take
pictures the lips the duck face all this
other stuff and you know these kids are
spoiled and you know they're having
issues because all they care about is
how many likes they're going to get and
it's such a problem it's catastrophic
and you know how the article ends
if you think this is catastrophic and
it's the end of the world maybe it just
means you're too old
yeah so so you ain't that's the that's
the hardest thing that for us we have to
consider because every time something
new happens we think it's the end of the
world okay we think it's the doomsday
and my only challenge to all of us is i
don't know if it is i don't know if it's
not but i will tell you what's the
biggest mistake if you don't immerse
yourself to learn about this world
you're screwed because the biggest thing
is to be ignorant about it it's better
to be you know learning about it so if
i'm a parent i'm definitely learning
about this stuff more than anybody
else's because i want to find out what
the hell is going to happen you're
losing your kid you're sick kid is
sitting there two hours upstairs not
coming downstairs he's got this stuff on
his eyes and you know like he's oculus
two whatever it is that they're looking
at it yeah i don't know i don't i i
don't know but basically saying the last
thing that you should be is dismissive
think about all the people who have been
dismissed it would be big crypto
whatever nfts how ridiculous is that
that's never going to work over the last
handful years and you're dismissing
people's perspectives and feelings and
you're missing out on the opportunity i
think being aware you said something a
few podcasts back which is really great
right the the people who are paranoid
survive right the paranoid survive so i
think it's i think it is good to be
skeptical and cynical about these things
but at the end of the day it's a tool
right it's technology and you can use it
for amazing things you were talking
about zoom yeah but there's something
about being here yes that's gonna put
you here we're gonna all be sitting next
to each other we're gonna feel each
other we're gonna see each other you
know what i mean so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]